WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KIM
JONG-UN.
NORTH KOREA SAID IT'S FREEZING
ITS TESTS FOR THE TIME BEING.
THE FRENCH PRESIDENT BEGINS A 3
DAY VISIT TO THE U.S. ON MONDAY.
THE FRENCH LEADER HAS A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP BUT ADMITS THEY DISAGREE
ON MAJOR ISSUES LIKE TRADE AND
THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
TODAY IN PARIS, FOX NEWS SUNDAY
ANCHOR CHRIS WALLACE SAT DOWN
WITH THE FRENCH PRESIDENT.
HERE'S A PREVIEW OF THAT
INTERVIEW.
>> WE CAME TO THE RESIDENCE OF
THE FRENCH PRESIDENT TO
INTERVIEW HIM.
ON THE EVE OF A STATE VISIT TO
WASHINGTON, WE DISCUSSED THE
MAJOR ISSUES HE AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP WILL TRY TO RESOLVE.
BUT I ALSO ASKED HIM WHETHER THE
INVESTIGATION BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL AND JAMES COMEY ATTACKS
HURT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S STANDING
ON THE WORLD STAGE.
>> HERE, I AM NOT THE ONE TO
JUDGE OR EXPLAIN TO YOUR PEOPLE
WHAT TO CONSIDER BECAUSE OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
YOUR PRESIDENT IS LESS CRED
ABELL.
>> DO YOU WONDER IF HE WILL
SERVE HIS FULLTERM?
>> I NEVER WONDER THAT.
I WORK WITH HIM BECAUSE WE WANT
VERY MUCH TO SERVE OUR COUNTRY.
>> WE WILL HAVE MUCH MORE OF OUR
INTERVIEW WITH THE FRENCH
PRESIDENT ON FOX NEWS SUNDAY
INCLUDING SHARP DIFFERENCES WITH
MR. TRUMP OVER TRADE AND THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
THAT'S IT FROM NOW IN PARIS.
BRET.
>> Bret: CHRIS WALLACE, YOU CAN